استشهد شابان واصيب ثالث واعتقل اخرون اثر
اقتحام القوات الاسرائيليه مدينه ومخيم
جنين وقد نعت حركه الجهاد الاسلامي
الشهيدين وتوعت بالرد على مقتلهما بينما
دعت حركه حماس تصعيد المقاومه ردا على
العدوان الاسرائيلي من جانب الاخر دعا
دبلوماسيان الامريكيين سابقان اداره بيضا
الى اتخاذ موقف صارم من الحكومه
الاسرائيليه المقبله
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذكر خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما هي التداعيات
المحتمله لاستمرار التصعيد الاسرائيلي
بالضفه والقدس وكيف سيتعاملوا الفلسطينيون
مع عمليات الاغتيال والاعتقالات
الاسرائيليه المتزايده ضدهم
الى اين يمكن ان يتجه التصعيد الاسرائيلي
ضد الفلسطينيين في ضوء ترجيح تولي اليمين
المتطرف ملف الامن في الحكومه المقبله وما
خيارات السلطه الفلسطينيه للتعامل مع هذا
الواقع الجديد وما موقفه واشنطن من
التصعيد ضد الاسرائيليين في ظل الحديث عن
تردد الامريكي في دعم حكومه اسرائيليه
يشارك فيها اليمين المتطرف
[موسيقى]
شباني فلسطينيان هما اخر من قتلته اسرائيل
في اقتحامتها المتكرره للضفه الغربيه
استشهد خلال اقتحام قوه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي مدينه ومخيمه جنين في عمليه
اسفرت ايضا عن اصابه فلسطينيه واعتقالي
اخرين الشباب
وقالت انهما من قاده كتيبه جنين وتوعدت
بالرد على مقتلهما السلطه الفلسطينيه طلبت
من جهتها بحمايه الفلسطينيين من
الانتهاكات الاسرائيليه ومنع الافلات من
العقاب بينما دعت حركه حماس الى تصعيد
المقاومه وتلبيه صرخه الاقصى الذي يتعرضوا
للتهديد والتهويد بحسب الحركه في المقابل
قال رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه لبيد ان
عمليه تجميل استمراره لسياسه اسرائيل
بمحاربه مسماه الارهاب
نادي الاسير الفلسطيني قال ان القوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اعتقلت عشره
فلسطينيين خلال عمليه دهم شملت مدن وقرا
فلسطينيه عده في الضفه الغربيه فجر وصباح
الخميس وان قوات الاحتلال اقتحمت مدن جنين
والخليل والقدس ورمى ونابلس
[موسيقى]
مناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضب الينا في بدايه
هذه الحلقه من تل ابيب امير اورين المحلل
السياسي والعسكري لشؤون الامن القومي
والسياسه الخارجيه الاسرائيليه ومن سان
فرانسيسكو
استاذ الامن الدولي وسياسه الخارجيه
بجامعه سان فرانسيسكو مرحبا بكم
ستيفن ما الذي تخشاه اداره بيضا من تولي
اليمين المتطرف
وزرات في حكومه التانيه
صور وجودها المجموعه
المتحده للمساعدات والدعم الامريكي
لاسرائيل دبلوماسيه وعسكريا وسياسيا يعتمد
على فكره ان اسرائيل هي الدوله
الديمقراطيه وان اسرائيل تمثل القيم
الليبراليه
المتحده
وصرف النظر عن سنوات كثيره من القمع
اسرائيل
الاتحاد غريب
وطبعا ان معروف ان سياسات هذا وقاده
المتطرفين يمنيا التي صدفقونها ستؤدي
المزيدنا للعنف المزيد من خلال الاستقرار
وسيشجع التطرف من الجانبين سيد اورينس كيف
يمكن ان ينظر بنيامين الثانيه الى هذا
التحفظ الامريكي لتولي يمين متطرف وزارات
في حكوميته
بشكل
او من الضيوف الاخرين لذلك سيد جزء من
المشكله في الشرق الاوسط قال لكن فيما
يتعلق بالسؤال
الكثير من الاسرائيليين ربما نصف السكان
اسرائيل
همم قريب ليكون بقلم شديد اساءه هذا
التوجه في الحكومه الجديده فهم ضد هذا
التوجه وهم يخافون مما قد تفعله الحكومه
هذه ليس فقط في الضفه الغربيه بل حتى داخل
اسرائيل وهو في الواقع
يطلعونا الى اداره لكي تعبر عن معارضتها
لاي شيء قد تقوم به هذه الحكومه واذا ما
تصرفوا بناء على همم وعود يتقدموها اثناء
الحمله الانتخابيه وارائهم التي طرحوها
على نلتهيه مكروهه بالنسبه لكثير
الاسرائيليه وبالتالي هذا
اكثر للرئيس الوزير خارجته الذي وعد في
يوم الاحد عندما خاطب مجموعه من المسيحيه
اليهوديين اللبنانيين وقال ان الكثير
الاسرائيلي سوف يدعمونا في وجهه هذا
لا لا يبدو بان
نتنياهو يعني سيستمع لهذه التحفظات
الامريكيه هو مضى اصلا في يعني الاتفاق مع
اييه مع بن جبير وفي طريقه ايضا الاتفاق
مع اسمه تريتش بالتالي هل من تداعيات
محتمله لعدم استماع نتنياهو لهذه الهواجس
الامريكيه في تشكيل الحكومه
لان اولوياته اصلا
حكومته وبالتالي هو لن
يدخل السجن للعدد اجراء ما التي وجهت اليه
سيقوم بهذه المجازه من اجل مصلحته الشخصيه
هو الولايات السياسيه الخاصه به ومع الاسف
هناك حقيقه انه في حين ان الولايات
المتحده بالتاكيد ستعبر
ومعارضه شمولها هؤلاء المتطرفين في
الحكومه فمن غير المحتر انه متحده قد تتخذ
اي اجراء ملموسه فعلا
استنكار قالوا هذا غير اقول لا انت تبغى
تتفعل ذلك فقط هذا ما فعلوه وبنت لك في
نهايه المطاف
المساعدات العسكريه غير لما شروطه ستستمر
ودعم اسرائيل في مجلس الامن سيستمر
وبالتالي لا في اي حال لا اعتقد ان كان
ينبغي ان يخلق من ايه تاثيرات
لذلك بعض المشاعر السيئه لكن لنكن
اكثر تطور المواقف الامريكيه قال كل من
ارون ميلر المفاوض السابق لشؤون الشرق
الاوسط في وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه
ودانيال كارترز السفير الامريكي السابق في
اسرائيل قال ان الاداره الامريكيه امام
اختبار لاظهار القوه اذ يتعين على البيت
الابيض تحذير اسرائيل من تغيير الوضع بما
يقود حال الدولتين واضاف ميلر في مقال
مشترك نشرته صحيفه واشنطن بوست ان على
اداره توضيح انها لن تتعامل مع ابن كثير
او اسمه اتش او وزارههما اذا استمروا في
تبني سياسات واجراءات عنصريه وان دعم
الولايات المتحده لاسرائيل في المحافل
الدوليه له حدود وفيما يتعلق بالجانب
الفلسطيني دعا الكاتبان البيت الابيض
لابلاغ القياده الفلسطينيه بان دعمهما
يعتمد على استعداد السلطه لاجراء انتخابات
وبناء حكومه ديمقراطيه مسؤوله ووقف ما
سمياه العنف والارهاب واضاف الدبلوماسيان
الامريكيان السابقان انه على واشنطن ابلاغ
الدول العربيه الموقعه على اتفاق ابرا بان
عدم اهتمام اهتمامها الواضح بمحنه
الفلسطينيين سوف يقود على علاقتهم مع
اسرائيل ويضر
بمصداقيتهم همم سيد همم القلق الامريكي هو
نابع من الحرص على الامن الاسرائيلي
بطبيعه الحال
هل بني امينه ياهو والحكومه المقبله معنيه
بمواجهه اداره بيدن فيما يتعلق بالامور
الداخليه الاسرائيليه
ليشعر بقلق شديد
فيما يتعلق بسياسه اداره
وتاريخيا كان علاقته السيئه مع الاداره
الديمقراطيه فقط علاقتها كانت جيده مع
رئيس واحد جمهوري الذي خدم اثناء فتره
الرئيس ترامب
ومره اخرى
يخاف من رد فعل الامريكي
وزاره الدفاع
بوصير سيكون مسؤولا عن الاداره المدنيه
المقصود بذلك وقدم السيد
ولكن عندما
اه اه وبعد شارون منك من وزير دفاع بقي
وزيرا للتجاره بعد صبرا وشتيله اييه
واشنطن ابعدته ولم تعترغب به
لا تكن بها اي علاقه بانغفير او سمعته هذا
حصل قد يكون نقطه مهمه وهذا قد يمكن اذا
القنصل العام الذي
نكرته
سوف
الازمه التي
وذلك سيكون امر جيدا فسر ستيفن همم ما
واجهت هذا التحفظ الامريكي على حكومه همم
عتيده همم اسرائيل همم تخرج القانونيه
الدوليه يوميا تختال في الشوارع تعتقل
وتماما تمارس انتهاكات كثيره بحق الشعب
الفلسطيني ااه يعني
ما واجهت هذه هذه المخاوف الامريكيه من ان
يحصل اسوا مما يحصل الان بالفعل على الارض
في الضفه الغربيه والقدس
تتعب عدد من الحكومات السابقه ان قامت بها
من اعمال القمع
السعودي للمدنيين في
اليمن واحتلال المغربي
الواقع اسرائيل ليستثناء كبير ولكن لان
اا الاسماعيلي
بسبب التهابات الكون الاتحاد الاسرائيليه
الشديده جدا ولانها تدور حول فكره اسرائيل
هي الديمقراطيه تتشاطر القيم التي تحبها
الولايات المتحده هو وبالتالي وجود مثل
هذه الاشخاص المتطرفين في السلطه هذا يجعل
يجعل لذلك من ناحيه السياسيه اصعب على
الولايات المتحده لكن الشيء الايجابي
لوحيد والذي اشار اليه الضيف الاخر هو
او ان ذلك سيؤدي المزيد من النقاشات
وانفتاح داخل المجتمع اليهودي هو وبالتالي
فان هناك داعمين اخرين وايضا داعمين
الاخرين لاسرائيل في الولايات المتحده
الان سيشعون بحريه اكبر للتعبير عن
سقطه من انتهاكات الموجوده لحقوق الانسان
بينما في السابق للتحدث ضد الحكومات
السابقه وبالتالي هذا الامر قد يؤدي الى
نوع من الانفتاح السياسي الذي علل في مع
بعض طبعا يمكن ان يؤدي الى
التغيرات المطلوبه جدا في الدعم الغير
مشروب التقديم الولايات المتحده لاسرائيلي
الكره فسر ستيفن زون ستبقى معنا من سان
فرانسيسكو نشكر في تل ابيب السيد امير
المحل السياسي والعسكري لشؤون الامن
القومي والسياسه الخارجيه الاسرائيليه
سيغادرنا ونرحب ب- همم الدكتور مصطفى
البرغوثي الامين العام لحركه المبادره
الوطنيه من رام الله دكتور مصطفى همم هل
هذا التحفظ الامريكي ذات مغزى وجدوى
بتقديركم انتم في فلسطين في فلسطين كيف
تنتظرون اليه
هذا تحفظ يعني لا ليس له تاثير كبير في
الواقع لانه الولايات المتحده تدعم
اسرائيل العسكريا تسكت على الاستيطان
والتوسع الاستيطاني الذي يقتل ما سمي بحل
الدولتين تسكت على الجرائم الاسرائيليه
يعني بضلوا يقولوا اسرائيل دوله
الاماراتيه اسرائيل مش دوله ديمقراطيه
اسرائيل كيان عنصري فاشي ارهابي يمارس
الارهاب بابشع صور ضد الشعب الفلسطيني
ويمارس نظام الابرتايد العنصري باعتراف كل
منظمات حقوق الانسان الرئيسيه في العالم
اذا همم التوصيف هنا ليس دقيقه
واليوم الجيش الاسرائيلي مليء بالفاسين
والا لماذا كلها هؤلاء الشهداء 210 شهداء
منذ بدايه هذا العام 9 شهداء في خلال 72
ساعه شهيد في المغير شهداء في جنين اشقاء
اثنان يعني ظافر الريماوي وجواد الريماوي
اخوه اثنان قاموا بقتلهم في نفس اللحظه
ما الذي يجري هذا ارهاب فاشي حقيقي يمارس
ضد الشعب الفلسطيني والولايات المتحده
تكتفي بالتحفظ شو يعني التحفظ اذا كانت
الولايات المتحده جاده
فلتفرض على اسرائيل اجراءات لوقف
الاستيطان فلتفرض على اسرائيل اجراءات
عقابيه لماذا في اوكرانيا 10000 عقوبه ضد
روسيا في خلال فتره اقل من شهر ولا عقوبه
واحده ضد اسرائيل على مدار 55 عام من
احتلال الضغط الغربيه و غزه
74 عام من نظام الابر تايد والتطهير
العراقيه لماذا هذا هذه الازدواجيه في
المعايير نحن لن يعني نواصل الاصغاء لهذا
الكلام همم السخيف
والعوده للقول ان على الفلسطينيين ان يوقف
العنف من يمارس العنف الفلسطينيون هم
الذين يتعرضوا للعنف الفلسطينيون هم من
يتعرضوا للاحتلال
ابناءهم كل يوم
السلطه الفلسطينيه اليوم بعد كل هذه
الجرائم مطالبه بشيء اكبر بكثير من مجرد
البيانات والاذانات والاستنكرات البيانات
والاذانات والاستنكرات لا تؤثر في اسرائيل
المطلوب وقف التنسيق الامني فورا من
المشين والمعيب ان يستمر التنسيق الامني
وهذه الجرائم ترتكب ضد الشعب الفلسطيني
المطلوب توحيد الصف الوطني فورا وانهاء كل
الانقسامات والتوحد على برنامج وطني كفاحي
مقاوم والتخلي عن الاوهام بامكانيه وجود
مفاوضات لن تحدث ابدا او تدخل امريكي لن
يصير نحن يجب ان لا يكون هناك مواصله
لاستجداء حمايه دوليه لن تحدث المطلوب
لاعتماد على النفس المطلوب تنظيم النفس
والمطلوب انتاج نهج كفاح الوطني لن تردع
اسرائيل الا بالمقاومه على الارض
وبعمل دولي واسع لفرد العزله عليها
والمقاطعه والعقبات وايضا بدعوه كل كل
بالعالم الى تصنيف هذه الحركات الفاشيه
الارهابيه بنج فير وسمو تريتش والاخرين
باعتبارها حركات ارهابيه وان يعلن عنها
كذلك الحزب الذي جاء منه بنجبير وسميترتش
هو نفسه كان مصنف حركه ارهابيه حتى في
الولايات المتحده وفي اسرائيل نفسه ستيفن
التقييم الدبلوماسي الامريكي بان الظروف
مهيئه للاشتعال عندما تستلم حكومه نتنياهو
السلطه تحديدا
بوجودك كثير همم كيف يمكن ان تتعامل
الاداره الامريكيه اذا خرجت الامور عن
السيطره في الضفه الغربيه والقدس وداخل
المناطق الاسرائيليه بتقديرك
فورشنر
مع الاسف انا خلق الولايات المتحده ليس هو
القمع المستمر تقوم باسرائيل
والهانات المستمره والعنف المستودعكم بها
اسرائيل ضد الفلسطينيين ما يهم هو ماذا
سيحصل لو ان الفلسطينيين ردوا على ذلك
ثم كيف تكون الحكومه الاسرائيليه
هذا يشبه
مقبول بالنسبه للولايات المتحده
التصعيد التصعيد باننا
بان القتال
والاشكال العلنيه في اللي هي المشكله
الوحيده ولكن من الواضح انه عندما يكون
هناك مثل
من هذا الاشكال الواضحه من اعمال العنف
لانها تبدو سيئه وتجعل الولايات المتحده
شكلها سيء وفي حين ولكن تكون هي الوسيطه
لعمليه سلام ونحن نوصل القول بان واصل
سياسات المزيد من السلام في حينما يحصل هو
العكس ذلك وبالتالي اخشى ان القلق
الامريكي هو لاسباب الاحراج السياسي
يشعرون به وليس بشعور حقيقي بالتزام
بالسلام والعداله الدكتور مصطفى طبعا
الفصائل الفلسطينيه وليست المره الاولى
تدعوا لتصعيد المقاومه همم كيف ترون هذا
وهل هو افضل خيارات بالمرحله المقبله
بوجود حكومه متطرفه يراسها
ليس افضل خيارات بل الخيال الوحيد لا يوجد
خير اخر امام الشعب الفلسطيني سوى
المقاومه والكفاح على الارض بكل الاشكال
بكل الاشكال كل الاشكال المقاومه لانه لا
يوجد طريقه لحمايه ابنائنا وحمايه انفسنا
وحمايه شعبنا وحمايه ارضنا سوى النضال
والكفاح ضد هذا الاجرام الذين تعرض له
لذلك هذا المسجد بين النضال والكفاح
المقاوم على الارض والذي انا برايي قد
تؤدي هذه الاحداث الى انتفاضه شعبيه شامله
في كل فلسطين في الواقع نحن نعيش حاله
انتفاضه لماذا تجري يعني كل مره يدخل جيش
الاحتلال الى المدن طبعا يجازيه الشبان
هناك هناك حاله غليان تجري على الارض
وغليان قد ينفجر في اي لحظه بشكل انتفاضه
شعبيه شامله لكن المطلوب هو الجمع بين هذه
المقاومه على الارض والكفاح على الارض
وايضا العمل على الصعيد عزل اسرائيل وفرض
المقاطعه والعقوبات عليها الامران
متوازيان ويجب ان يجريان بشكل متوازي من
ناحيه اخرى الجمهور الفلسطيني يطالب
فصائله بالتوحد يطالب بوجود قياده وطنيه
موحده كما كان عليه الحال في الانتفاضه
الشعبيه الاولى هذا مطلب كبير ولذلك يجب
تنحيه الخلافات والانقسامات
والانتهاء من حاله الصراع على الصداقات
سفاره الامارات في تل ابيب وجه الدعوه
لابن كثير لحضور حفل بمناسبه الاستقلال
الخمسين للامارات العربيه المتحده كيف
تنظرون الى اطراف التطبيع اطراف ابرامز في
هذه المرحله الحرجه لو سمحت
اولا توجيه دعوه لبن كبير من اي انسان
عربي
وبما في ذلك سفاره الامارات امر مخزي مخزي
ومشينا برايي لا يوجد وصف اخر له هذا امر
مخزي ان يدعى هذا الارهابي مثل هذا
الاحتفال ولكن انا جوابي لك جاوبت في شعوب
العربيه في مونديال قطر هذا الضيق
الاسرائيلي يقول نحن معزولون نحن محاصرون
لان الشعوب العربيه اثبتت في همم مباريات
كاس العالم في قطر وكان هذا معبر جدا انها
كل الشعوب العربيه مع الشعب الفلسطيني
حكومات تطبع هذا موقف سيبقى معزوله لان
الشعوب مع الشعب الفلسطيني وقضيته العادل
شكرا لكم الدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي الامين
عندي حركه المبادره الوطنيه والبروفيسير
ستيفنوس استاذ الامن الدولي والسياسه
الخارجيه بجامعه سان فرانسيسكو
الى هنا تنتهي الحلقه من برنامج نور الخبر
شكرا متابعه الى اللقاء بامان الله
ورعايته
[موسيقى]